continuous integration continuous
deployment and build tools
learning objectives
by the end of this lesson you will be
able to
describe the importance of continuous
integration and continuous deployment
list the features of jenkins and
demonstrate their uses list the features
of team city and demonstrate their uses
and select a suitable tool for your
organization
the overview and importance of
continuous integration and continuous
deployment
overview of continuous integration
continuous integration is a development
practice of combining code from a number
of different developers into a common
code base intended for deployment
each integration event is verified by
automated build and automated tests
there are many aspects to a continuous
integration also known as ci process
continuous integration is a development
practice of combining code from a number
of different developers into a common
codebase intended for deployment
each integration event is verified by
automated build and automated tests
there are many aspects to a continuous
integration also known as ci process
these are develop and compile code
perform unit tests
integrate code with various types of
databases perform pre-production
deployment activities for example moving
code to various types of computing
environments such as testing and staging
also part of a continuous integration
process is to perform functional testing
and apply labels against release points
in the code repository additional
activities in ci are to generate reports
and analyze the code
continuous integration is about
combining code from each developer into
a common deployment path automatically
with a high degree of accuracy
continuous integration is more than a
developer just creating some code and
committing it to a feature branch he or
she is working on for automation to pick
up and deploy
instead the developer needs to make sure
that he or she writes unit tests that
exercise each line of code written
the purpose of unit testing is to prove
that the code that's written works to
expectation
a standard feature of most shops that
practice continuous integration is to
have the process run all the unit tests
in the developer's work branch before
merging the code into a common code base
if the unit tests don't pass in the
automated process the developer's code
is not merged into the common branch
then the developer is typically notified
either by email or by another
communication channel that there's a
problem that needs to be corrected
overview of continuous deployment
continuous deployment is an extension of
continuous integration
its purpose is to reduce the time
between a development team writing code
and then using it in
production the benefits of continuous
deployment are not only that it provides
faster feedback from end users as each
new feature is released to production
but it also realizes a faster return on
investment for each feature as it gets
developed
for the most part continuous deployment
is a highly automated process that
reduces the need for human interaction
in the deployment process
scripts take over most of the work that
used to be done by humans previously
involved in the physical deployment of
code
not only does automation copy code from
one computing environment to another
the scripts will actually create the
computing environments that need to be
in place before you can move the code
along
automation reduces the time it takes to
get code from developer to end user and
increases the accuracy of the code
that's being produced
continuous deployment makes sure that
the right code is in the right place at
the right time
popular tools in continuous integration
and continuous deployment
the more common cicd tools used in it
shops practicing devops are jenkins
travis ci bamboo team city and get lab
continuous integration with jenkins
jenkins is one of the more popular tools
in the devops landscape it's a powerful
framework that supports a broad plug-in
ecosystem
instead of having to write code on a
line-by-line basis to extend the power
of jenkins developers write custom
plugins to add new functionality these
plugins are highly reusable
so much so that a whole marketplace has
evolved around the product there are now
over a thousand plugins available and
most of these are free
also jenkins integrates with over a
hundred other devops tools such as
github and testing tools from a variety
of vendors
jenkins allows devops personnel to
reliably orchestrate the release tool
chain
and it's designed to be an end-to-end
solution
in order to get full benefit from using
jenkins aspiring devops personnel need
to understand the standard phases in the
cicd pipeline
these phases are code and commit build
and configure
scan and test
release and deploy
you're going to incorporate a variety of
tools with jenkins during each phase of
the process
during code and commit developers use an
integrated development environment also
known as an ide to create code
the popular ones are visual studio
visual studio code and eclipse and then
they'll check the code into a version
control system such as get github
perforce or mercurial
some code might require binary
dependencies that are stored in an
artifact repository such as artifactory
after code is created and committed it
needs to be built
if the code requires compilation into a
binary file such as a dll exe or jar
file jenkins will use a build system
such as ms build a c compiler maven for
java or and for more general purposes if
the code needs to be containerized
you'll use docker
some itshops will automatically create
computing environments during build and
configure in anticipation of impending
code deployments
tools such as puppet chef and ansible
can provision virtual machines
automatically according to pre-defined
configurations
in during the scan and testing phase
you'll integrate jenkins with testing
tools such as junit j meter cucumber or
ms test
front end testing can be conducted using
selenium appium saw slab or euler packer
products
the purpose of scan and test is to make
sure the code meets quality standards
and is safe to move forward in the cicd
process
the release phase is the last stage
before code is released to users
you might integrate jenkins with tools
such as you deploy serena midvision or
excel release
finally for deploy you'll go on-premises
to a cloud service or a hybrid
combination of both a private
on-premises cloud and a public cloud
for public cloud deployments you'll
target amazon web services
google cloud azure or ibm cloud
also we're seeing cloud orchestration
technologies such as kubernetes take an
increased presence as a release platform
for a private cloud there's openstack
if you're working directly with virtual
machines you'll integrate jenkins with
vmware products or docker at a high
level in terms of application runtimes
you'll need something like the jboss
java virtual machine or the websphere
application server
jenkins provides operational consistency
in the various stages of release
regardless of the particular products
you plan to use thus you'll do well to
keep these phases of deployment in mind
as you continue on your journey to
devops mastery
continuous deployment with jenkins
as you can see in the slide continuous
deployment which we abbreviate as cd
consists of five operational stages
the first stage is coding which is
typically done on the developer's local
workstation
the next stage is storage
during the storage phase a developer
commits his or her code to a source
control management system such as get
moving the code into a separate test
computing environment ensuring that the
code is implemented in the best way
possible in addition to ensuring that
the code works according to expectation
so that it can be released to production
is done in the quality assurance and
testing stages
production is the final stage in the
release process
production is where the code is made
available to end users
the value that jenkins brings to the
software development life cycle is that
it can be configured to automate every
stage of the entire process
this is very important because it not
only speeds up the software development
process overall but also increases the
accuracy and reliability of the code
under development
companies such as linkedin google and
facebook have made continuous deployment
a fundamental part of the way they make
software
it's only by using an automation tool
such as jenkins that effective
continuous deployment is possible
doing deployment manually is time
consuming and costly those who adhere to
the principles of devops understand that
continuous deployment is an essential
part of the practice of software
development in the modern enterprise
and automation is key to the practice
continuous integration with teamcity
teamcity is a free continuous
integration tool from jetbrains the
company is best known for its integrated
development environments for writing
software
the abbreviation for integrated
development environment is ide
team city is a complete continuous
deployment continuous integration system
designed to automatically manage all
aspects of the software development life
cycle
team city is designed to integrate with
all the popular products used in modern
software development it integrates well
with the standard web browsers as we've
learned previously communication among
and between teams is important thus team
city can be configured to send out
notifications using email rss chat tools
and social media platforms such as slack
it supports version control by
integrating with source control
management systems such as get
subversion
perforce as well as many others
teamcity supports all the build tools
and development frameworks commonly
found in the enterprise such as ant
maven ms build and grunt
also teamcity can be integrated with
popular ides such as eclipse the various
jetbrain tools such as intellij webstorm
and pycharm
teamcity also integrates easily with the
industry standard for developing
microsoft technologies visual studio and
visual studio code
continuous deployment with teamcity
a good way to understand the workflow
that teamcity is designed to manage by
way of automation is to conceptualize
the software development process as
having three areas of activity
artifact deployment and operations
let's take a look at each area in detail
artifact activity is about managing the
various code components that make up a
software system
some shops use the term deployment unit
to describe the distinct component of
code that needs to be released into
production
other shops use the term deployment
artifact
some of these components might be a
binary file such as java or a jar file
or in dot-net shops the artifacts can be
an exe or dll file
linux doesn't have the concept of file
extension based executables thus any
file can be an executable you just need
to have the right permission set
the important thing to understand about
the artifact area is that it's about
creating and managing deployment units
that will be released to production
deployment
once an artifact or collection of
artifacts are ready for release they
need to go through a company's
deployment process there are a number of
tools and processes associated with
deployment activity
the ultimate goal of the deployment
activity is to make sure that working
valuable software gets to the customer
as quickly as possible
typically companies will use a ticketing
system to control and monitor the work
that needs to be done in deployment
artifacts will be prepared for
deployment
computing instances will be provisioned
sometimes the provisioning might involve
creating virtual computing instances
such as a virtual machine or container
other times it might require installing
physical hardware such as computers and
networking devices
then after provisioning is complete the
deployment artifacts are configured and
pushed into relevant computing
environments
and finally we get to operations
it's important to understand that a
comprehensive ci cd system such as team
city goes beyond just deployment
activity
team city will also automate a lot of
operations activity
release personnel can use team city
features to orchestrate computing
environments and monitor activity in
those environments
also it coordinates important aspects of
enterprise level devops such as logging
and aggregating security alerts
security is a critical aspect of any
enterprise's operation and is a
particular concern to any devops
practitioner working within the
enterprise
overview and features of jenkins
jenkins as a continuous integration tool
jenkins is a java based open source
automation tool it functions as a server
and is a software development and
cross-platform tool used for continuous
integration and continuous deployment
let's look at what jenkins can do
as a continuous integration server it
can be used as a ci server or a
continuous delivery hub for a project
in terms of distribution it can easily
distribute work across different
machines and help trigger builds test
and deployments to multiple machines and
platforms quickly
jenkins is designed to work
cross-platform
it allows programming in software
development environments such as ios.net
android ruby and java
architecture of jenkins
jenkins is a comprehensive ci cd
framework that is designed to be
flexible and extensible
it has a distinct object model that has
classes like project and build
these classes describe the various
components of the framework
it uses jelly as the view technology
it uses the file system to store its
data directories are created at the
location on disk
defined by the environmental variable
jenkins underscore home
it supports plugins which are plugged
into those extension points and extend
the capabilities of jenkins
popular features of jenkins
let's take a look at the features
one jenkins is platform independent
two it has a rich plugin system
three it has the support of a large
community of third-party developers and
expert users
four it's designed to scale to meet the
needs of the large enterprise
five its automation capabilities enable
immediate detection and resolution of
issues
six it's open source and user friendly
and seven
it's easy to configure
modify and extend
build status and job health
every time a jenkins job runs the status
of the build gets reported
the figure on the left side of the slide
shows the results of a few runs of a
build project
notice that the result of each build is
reported
sometimes the build succeeds
other times it fails
if an administrator aborts or disables
the build
that gets reported too
the figure on the right side of the
slide provides a description of the
overall health of the project according
to many builds
assisted practice set up jenkins
let's take a look at the assisted
practice
you are given a project to install and
configure jenkins on the ubuntu
operating system of your learning lab
virtual machine
lab 3.1
installing and configuring jenkins
in this demo we're going to describe
three steps to install and configure
jenkins
first we're going to modify the file
sources.list
then we're going to use app get to
install the jenkins package and then
finally we're going to run jenkins in
the browser
so let's get started
first at the command line we type make
dir lab 3.1
then at the command line we type
cd
lab 3.1 to navigate into the directory
we've just created
now
we need to add the key from the jenkins
package repository into our local
environment
at the command line we type
wget
dash q
dash o
https
colon slash slash package dot jenkins
dot io
slash
debian dash stable slash jenkins dot io
dash key
pipe
sudo
apt
dash key add dash
and this will add the key directly into
the app get file system
now we need to update the file
sources.list
we'll use the vi editor that's already
installed in your classroom virtual
machine
at the command line we type
sudo space
vi space forward slash etc
forward slash ept
forward slash sources dot list
sources dot list is the file that
apt-get uses to locate package
repositories on the internet
we strike the i key on the keyboard to
put vi into insert mode
we scroll down to an empty space in vi
and type
deb
https colon forward slash forward slash
g dot jenkins dot io
forward slash debian dash stable
space
binary forward slash
then
we hit the escape key to get out of
insert mode and type colon
w for write
q to quit vi
now we have to update the package
manager
at the command line we type sudo
apt-get space update
update executes
once we see the line reading package
lists dot dot done the update is
complete
now we need to see if java is installed
and if not we need to install it
at the command line we type java space
dash version
as you can see
java and the java development kit is
already installed
if java was not installed you would type
sudo space apt dash get space
install
space
o p e n
j d k
dash seven
dash j o j r e
this command will execute app get to
install the open jdk package
now we install jenkins type sudo space
app dash get space install space jenkins
strike the y key to confirm installation
the installation process will take a few
seconds
now we're going to open the initial
installation of jenkins in a browser
we go back to the virtual machine
desktop
in this case we'll load the firefox
browser
we're going to enter the ip address of
the jenkins installation
the ip address was assigned to the
virtual machine earlier
in the address bar of the firefox
browser
we enter the ip address 172.31.26.js
colon 8080
8080 is the port where the jenkins
server is running
please be advised the ip address of your
virtual machine will be different and
the way you can discover the ip address
is at the command line type ifconfig
the ip address of your virtual machine
will be in the information displayed
the first screen we're shown is the
unlock jenkins screen
we're going to need to enter the
administrator password in order to
continue as you can see in the red type
the location of the password is a file
slash var slash live slash jenkins slash
secrets slash initial admin password
where initial admin password is the name
of the file that contains the password
we return to the terminal
we type clear to clear the screen
at the command line we type
sudo space
cat
space
forward slash var forward slash live
forward slash jenkins forward slash
secrets
forward slash initial
admin password
we strike the enter key to display the
password
we highlight the password in the
terminal
and then copy it by right-clicking on
the mouse and selecting copy
we return to the browser
and paste the password into the
administrator password text box
then we click the continue button
firefox will offer to save the password
but we'll click don't save
we have the option to install suggested
plugins
or we can select specific plugins to
install
we're going to go with the install
suggested plugins method
we click the box labeled install
suggested plugins
the getting started page appears and the
plugin installation continues
once downloading and installing the
plugins is complete you'll be presented
with the create first admin user page
at this point we've successfully
installed jenkins
now the next steps will be to create the
admin user by putting in a username
password confirmation of password a full
name for the user and the user's email
address
let's recap the important steps
assisted practice guidelines to install
and configure jenkins
log into ubuntu lab provided with the
course
open the terminal and execute the
command available in the lab document
3.1 to add the key to the system
edit the sources.list file and add the
command to the file and then save it
update the apt-get package
install jdk 8 plus version install
jenkins using app get package
navigate to the ip address of the
machine denoted as x point x point x
point x colon 8080 in the browser of
your virtual machine
get the password and enter it into the
jenkins window
create a new role job in jenkins
explore the freestyle project and build
section
overview and the features of team city
team city as a continuous integration
tool
team city is a java based management and
continuous integration server
it's licensed commercial software that's
used for continuous integration and
continuous deployment
teamcity supports a number of features
that are important to the continuous
integration process
for example
gated commits ensure only working code
is committed to deployment branches and
source control
teamcity supports integration with
various integrated development
environments such as eclipse and
intellij
it has a build grid that describes build
activity
also it has cross-platform support for a
variety of operating systems and
programming languages
also teamcity has seamless code
integration
teamcityworkflow
teamcity supports the cicd process that
has become the standard workflow for
many companies and software development
shops
let's take a look at the overall
workflow
as you can see in the slide at point 1
the first step is that a developer or
tester checks code in to the source
control management system
upon commit at point 2 a build trigger
message is sent to the team city server
then at point 3 team city works with
system unit testing to start the system
unit testing automation process if the
code passes the tests
artifact building archiving and
deployment tasks are performed in an
automated manner at point four
team city reports the status of all the
activities at point five
popular features of team city
team city has many features that make
the cicd process more efficient let's
take a look at the features
teamcity has pre-tested commit
instant notifications
it has code coverage and monitoring
capabilities it provides a comprehensive
build infrastructure and it has enhanced
version control system integration
teamcity makes it easy to verify code
and it offers configurable test reports
and finally teamcity supports managing
users and roles
assisted practice
set up teamcity
now it's time to do an assisted practice
to set up teamcity
you're going to be given a project to
install and configure team city on the
ubuntu operating system in your learning
lab virtual machine so let's get started
with lab 3.2 install and configure team
city
first we create a directory for the work
we type mkdir
lab
3.2
then we navigate to that directory by
typing cd space
lab 3.2
first we're going to download the
compressed gz file for teamcity
then we're going to extract the files
from the compressed file
we're going to move the extracted
directory that contains the files into
another location
we're going to start up teamcity
and then we're going to go to the
browser
and register a user with teamcity
let's download teamcity
we go to the desktop of our classroom
virtual machine
and then we click on the icon for google
chrome
chrome appears
in the chrome address bar we type
www.jetbrains.com
forward slash team city
forward slash download
we click the download button
the gz file downloads and the thank you
page appears
we return to the terminal
at the command line we type cd space
forward slash home
forward slash ubuntu
forward slash capital downloads forward
slash
we strike the enter key
this takes us to the directory where the
gz file has been downloaded
at the command line we type ls to
confirm that the gz file is indeed in
the directory
notice the file teamcity-2018.2.1.tar.gz
is listed
now we need to extract the files
at the command line we type tar space
zxvf
space
teamcity-2018.2.1
and we hit the enter key
this will extract all the files into a
directory named team city
now we need to move the directory team
city
into the directory
forward slash opt forward slash jet
brains
we create a directory by typing
pseudo space
mkdir
space
forward slash opt
forward slash capital jet capital brains
now we need to move the directory team
city
into the directory forward slash opt
forward slash jet brains
at the command line we type
sudo space mv
space
team city
forward slash opt forward slash jet
brains forward slash team city
we strike the enter key
now we need to give
full read write and execute permissions
to the files in the newly created
directory team city
at the command line we type cd space
forward slash opt forward slash jet
jetbrains
we strike the enter key
then we type chmod space
dash capital r
team city forward slash this says to
give all rights to the directory and the
contents of the directory team city
we type ls just to make sure the
directory team city is indeed there
we type cd space team city forward slash
and hit the enter key to enter the
directory team city
then we type ls to take a look at the
contents of the directory team city
notice there is a bin directory
we navigate into the bin directory by
typing cd space bin and hit the enter
key
let's clear the screen to make things
easier to see
to invoke team city
we will execute the bash file
dot forward slash team city dash server
dot sh
space start
it's very important that you use the dot
forward slash characters
we hit the enter key and team city
starts up spawning team city and then
team city restarter running with pid
and the pid the process identifier will
vary according to systems
now teamcity is running we go back to
the browser
but before we do take notice of the ip
address of the virtual machine
which is shown on the command line on
the left hand side
the ip address of this virtual machine
is
172.31.26.234
in the address bar of the chrome browser
we type
172.33
colon 811
which is the port on the ip address
where team city is running
the team city first start web page
appears
we click the proceed button
the team city is starting page appears
then we see the database connection
setup page
teamcity allows you to choose from a
variety of databases
we can use postgres mysql oracle or ms
sql server
we're going to use the internal database
teamcity creates the database
and initializes its server components
this phase of the setup can take a few
minutes
the page will reload automatically once
teamcity is through installing its
server components
we're almost done with teamcity's
installation process then
all we'll need to do is to create an
account in teamcity
when the installation process is
complete we'll be presented with the
licensing agreement that we have to
agree to
we scroll to the end of the terms and
conditions
we click the check box for accept
license agreement
we're going to uncheck send anonymous
usage statistics
then we'll click the continue button
the webpage create administrator account
appears
we enter the username simplylearn
then we add a password and confirm the
password
finally we click the button create
account
we'll also save the username and
password information in google chrome
upon successfully entering a username
and password will be presented with the
my settings and tools web page in
teamcity
the page allows us to access projects
and changes
and agents
as well as build cues
the next demo we'll look at more details
let's recap the important steps
guidelines to install and configure
teamcity
number one
log in to ubuntu lab provided with the
course
number two download team city from the
official site
three unzip the folder and install
teamcity
four provide the read write and execute
mode access to seem city
number five
run team city at x dot x dot x dot x
colon eight one one one where x dot x
dot x dot x is the ip address of your
local machine or the machine where the
server is running
six create an account in team city and
add the basic details to complete the
setup process
seven explore options such as projects
changes agents and build queue
build tools and their uses
build tools
build tools are programs that automate
the creation of applications from source
code
automation tools allow the build process
to be more consistent
some common build tools are make bash
which ships with linux and apache maven
for java
grunt and gulp
popular features of build tools
well we can start with compiling to
binary code for languages such as
c-sharp and java
build tools will package a compiled
program for deployment
also it will run automated test cases
against the code the build tool will
deploy artifacts to production and also
generate documents for developers to use
for later reference
and finally a build tool will generate
release notes
an overview of apache ant
apache ant is a java library and command
line tool
its aim is to provide processes
described in build files as targets and
extension points dependent on each other
let's take a look at some of the
distinct features
apache ant supplies a number of built-in
tasks that allow it to compile test and
run code
it's flexible and does not impose coding
conventions
it builds solutions by combining build
tools and dependencies with apache ivy
it solves makes portability problem
and users can develop custom ant lives
using java
and finally you can use ant to pilot any
type of process
the limitations of apache ant
in apache and there are a few
limitations
some of the limitations are number one
configuration error checking is limited
undefined properties are not raised as
errors but are left as unexpanded
references
number two ant has limited fault
handling rules
lazy property evaluation is not
supported thus you need to be very exact
when configuring at
it is not a forgiving environment
number three older tasks use default
values which are not consistent and can
cause problems you need to pay attention
changing defaults can break existing ant
scripts and finally number four ant
build files are complex and verbose as
they are hierarchical and partly ordered
an overview of maven
apache maven is a comprehensive software
project management tool
based on the project object model also
known as the pom maven can manage a
project's build
reporting and documentation from a
central xml file let's take a look at
the key points of maven number one is
backward compatibility and auto parent
versioning the hierarchical structure of
the palm xml file reduces the burden on
version control and reconciliation of
dependencies
number two
maven supports model based builds
number three maven supports parallel
builds and better error integrity
reporting
you can kick off a number of project
builds that run asynchronously
number four
release management and distribution
publication is built into maven
the project object model is
comprehensive and covers all aspects of
the software development life cycle from
development through testing and onto
release
number five
instant access to the latest features
with less or no additional configuration
maven allows artifact version control
that can be set to get the latest
release of a dependency
thus you can make sure the code is
always up to date
six
large and growing repositories there is
a complete ecosystem of maven artifact
repositories that make it so you have
access to popular components
automatically
the maven repository found at https
slash mavenrepository.com
is a popular one
also a company can set up its own
private
repository the drawbacks of maven maven
does have some drawbacks number one
unable to depend on outcome status
maven builds can fail leaving nothing
behind other than error messages that
can be very hard to understand
number two maven is verbose and complex
it does take a while to master the
details of the platform
number three
slow and partial black box
maven does a lot of things automatically
and sometimes these black box activities
can be very opaque and finally number
four
maven can be unreliable when integrated
for use within the eclipse ide
comparing maven over ant
well
maven has better dependency management
it provides more powerful builds
there's better collaboration and the
debugging capabilities are a bit better
than ant
there's more componentization in the
builds and there's reduced duplication
and finally the palm provides a more
consistent project structure
the project object model also known as
the pom
the project object model is an xml
representation of a maven project
it provides general configuration
information
such as a project's name its owner and
its dependencies on other projects
the xml excerpt in the slide shows a
rudimentary implementation of maven's
project object model
the palm xml needs to define the group
id the artifact id and version
the packaging needs to be declared too
the default deployment package is a jar
the project described in the xml file in
the slide has an artifact id of
calculator
you can think of the artifact id as the
name of the artifact that's going to be
created
the pom shows a version of 1.0 and it
belongs to the group with the identifier
eu dot total eclipse
you can think of the group id as a way a
company organizes a number of artifacts
under a common name
overview of grunt
grunt is a javascript based task runner
which is used to automate repetitive
tasks in a workflow
it can be used as a command line tool
for javascript objects
let's take a look at some of the key
points to understand about grunt
in grunt developers write grunt setup
files to ease workflow
thus grunt speeds up the development
flow and enhances performance
it helps with the automation of
repetitive tasks with less effort
it supports a small infrastructure which
is a best fit
for new code bases grunt minifies files
such as html and css thus reducing the
potential problems with network latency
grunt aims at reducing the chances of
errors during repetitive tasks
and it includes built-in tasks to extend
functionality of plugins
currently grunt has over 4 000 plugins
and can be used in large production
sites
an overview of gulp
gulp is an open source javascript
toolkit used as a build system in
front-end web development
it automates time-consuming and
repetitive tasks involved in development
some of the key features of grunt are
code minification and concatenation
usage of pure javascript code grunt
converts files created under less or sas
in a css compilation process less which
stands for leaner style sheets is a
dynamic preprocessor style sheet
language that can be compiled into
cascading style sheets also known as css
and these style sheets are run on the
client side or the server side
sas is a preprocessor scripting language
that is interpreted or compiled into
cascading style sheets
grunt also manages file manipulation in
memory
some of the advantages of grunt are that
it's easy to code it's easy to test with
web apps and the plugins are simple to
use
some of the disadvantages of grunt are
there's more than the usual number of
dependencies
multiple tasks cannot be performed in
parallel and configuration can become
tedious
assisted practice continuous integration
with jenkins and maven
you are given a project to configuring
jenkins
you need to make jenkins poll get
commits and build a project code using
maven on the ubuntu operating system on
your practice lab vm
okay so let's get started with lab 3.3
continuous integration
with jenkins git and maven
in this lab we're going to configure
jenkins to support get and maven
then we're going to configure a maven
project
and then finally we're going to build
the maven project using source code from
get
so in a web browser we open jenkins and
what we do in our classroom virtual
machine is we go to the ip address and
in this case it's
172.31 dot
colon 8080 and jenkins typically runs by
default installation
we click the new item link which is on
the upper left of the jenkins web page
the new item web page appears
in the new project text box we enter the
project name in this case java maven
then we select freestyle project
then scroll down the web then scroll
down the web page and click the ok
button on the left hand side
the web page for the newly created
project
loads
we add text to the description text box
this is a simple project to test jenkins
we go to the menu bar at the top of the
projects web page and we click the build
tab
we're taken to the build section of the
web page
we click the add bill step button to
display a drop-down of options
from that drop-down list we select the
item execute shell
in the command text box we enter the
linux command
echo
space
quotation mark hello space from space
jenkins quotation
we click the save button on the lower
left
now we'll do a test build to make sure
everything's working all right
on the left hand side of the project web
page we click the link build now
the build starts
and when it completes you'll see a blue
circular icon in the build history
section of the project web page on the
left side and you can see there's a
build there
and it's labeled number one
to the right of build number one is a
drop down arrow which we click to get a
list of options and we select console
output
selecting console output will display in
the web page
the build log activity
notice there's a line that says hello
jenkins this is from the echo command we
entered in the jenkins build
configuration
let's develop the project a little more
what we need to do is to add get
integration and get the project to work
with maven
we go to the simply learn site on github
and that's simply learn devops official
and we go to the repository java maven
app
on the github site we click the green
clone or download button to display the
url that we can use to access
to access the java maven app repository
on github so we highlight the url and
copy it
we go back to the jenkins web page
in the jenkins web page on the menu bar
we click the tab for the java maven
project the java maven project appears
on the left side of the project's web
page we click the configure hyperlink
this loads the project's configuration
page
in which we click the source code
management tab
we're navigated to the source code
management section of the configuration
page
there we click the option get
we paste the url of our simply learn
java maven app repository into the text
box repository url
entering a valid url will make the error
message please enter get repository
disappear
we're going to select some predefined
credentials from the credentials drop
down
we added those earlier but if you need
to add credentials in the future
simply click the add button and then
select jenkins
now if you're using your own
github repository you'll be presented
with the jenkins credentials provider
dialog
you're going to need to enter your
username and also your password
once we configure access
to the get repository we click the save
button
now what we've done is we've effectively
given jenkins the right to access our
github account using our credentials in
other words jenkins is impersonating us
after we save the get configuration
we'll be brought back to the projects
page
we need to go back to jenkins home
we click
the jenkins tab on the upper left of the
project page
this takes us back to the main jenkins
dashboard page which we can think of as
home
now we click manage jenkins on the left
side of the jenkins home page
on the manage jenkins page we select
global tool configuration
the global tool configuration page
appears
we scroll down to the maven section of
the global tool configuration page we
click on the button add maven to add a
maven configuration
we're going to give this installation a
name we're going to call it localmaven
then maven needs to know where its home
is on the classroom virtual machine
in the text box labeled maven underscore
home
we enter the value
slash usr slash share slash maven
an alternative method is to again click
on add maven
add a name this time maven
and then from the install from apache
drop-down
select the version of maven that's on
the machine
we've now let jenkins know about maven
so we can click the save button
we return to the manage jenkins page
we need to return to the project
in the upper left hand corner of the
manage jenkins page we click the jenkins
button we're brought back to the jenkins
main dashboard you can see java maven in
the list of projects on the main
dashboard when we hover over
java maven we'll see a down arrow we
click that down arrow and some options
appear
we select configure from the options
drop down
the java maven projects configuration
page appears
we click the build tab in the menu bar
you can see the echo command that we
created previously in the build section
we want to get rid of it so what we're
going to do is we're going to go to the
right side of the execute shell section
and click the red button with the x
label
clicking the red button deletes the
execute shell command echo from the
build section
now we want to add a new build step
we click the add build step button and
we notice that another drop down appears
from that drop down we select invoked
top level maven targets
after we add the maven build task we'll
be presented with a maven version drop
down
this will contain the maven
configurations we created previously
we select one of the configurations in
this case we'll select maven
let's recap the important steps assisted
practice guidelines to configure jenkins
and maven
number one
log in to ubuntu lab provided with the
course number two log into jenkins and
create their first jenkins job number
three install and configure maven number
four configure jenkins with java get and
maven number five create a jenkins job
for your maven build project and run the
project
number six
poll get for commits and automatically
trigger the build
number seven build the trigger using the
push mechanism instead of pull
number eight repeat steps six and seven
multiple times to observe the results in
the console output section
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here